so my birthday's next week David this
next week yeah the truth is what's today
the 20th holy [ __ ] I read this in five
days I know how old are you 10 H I miss
that Camry I've banged my head on that
Camry so many times fed acid that's
where do you please just get in the car
how's her head is huge haven't you
noticed yeah he's bobble head I always
bump into like I always hit the top of
his car whenever I get it got in bobble
head but you felt and you know how my
head feels like it's abnormally round
like you know some people like the flat
in the bed I'm round all around know why
she's my ass out yeah oh poor woman I
know right and she still pays for it
till this day she's pees randomly you
see her on snapchat on my snapchat you
know you don't want to reception just
coming up one huh wait July 25th I don't
feel I know this figures I got like 400
tweets people [ __ ] hate me
oh by the way July 25th don't forget her
birthday I never got so much [ __ ] about
somebody's birthday in my life I only
forgot what it's what oh god it's so
good I'm getting all those tweets too
and it's so funny because I know you see
them too I remembered I don't even know
what what happened and either you just
keep saying that I forgot it which I
don't remember forgetting yes God he
forgets my birthday and he even forgets
it you forgot
my friend I didn't matter that we
remember and then forgetting my birthday
didn't matter enough to remember either
I remember a few bad I remember there
wasn't I woke up and there was something
of missing the force the great
disturbance in the force as if millions
of voices suddenly cried out in terror
wait weather I told you I was gonna take
you out for your birthday yeah you're
like save that date for your birthday
you know any forget that you even forgot
you forget you forgot that you also feel
bad terrible person oh my god forgotten
you like remember no [ __ ] Emma I'm so
sorry but no you forgot that you're so
sorry my [ __ ] phasers I gotta roll
but you've never opened the first place
nobody takes her out
disappointed what are the chances that
something would do something things
because people don't remember that
person forgets just call me I told him I
don't like celebrating my birthday yeah
consider after 21 knowing it like I
don't you [ __ ] about my birthday
hey no we gotta do something and this
was by the way a month
he was hella high a month in advance
so that same night I get it I get a
video Jennifer Bailey's gets me Cynthia
video him singing which was effect care
like this because I was working in
little tire event it was during the day
and fans were coming to the booth and I
was signing and then I get a text
message from David I was like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] one not only did he
not take me out but he made it worse by
sending me a video himself it was the
common thing I don't want what I said
video Danielle not hey have your
birthdays hey I'm not sure if it's your
birthday my god happy birthday because I
was reading all the stuff people saying
what's a happy birthday - everybody know
if it was the day before or the after or
people are saying it early
so June day view state or are you and
David dating like do you think we're
[ __ ] dating with this muffler can't
even remember my [ __ ] birthday that's
right that's real love teach him
Jim and I used to be lovers ghetto for
this place I don't know I don't know hey
I know we're in for an adventure Daniel
it might be some he'll get a possible
Nevada
I don't know but they're selling click
like I don't know eighty nine ninety
seven though before I want to click like
on your chest
the penalty is $90 to get shot no not
doctor chest and yellow for drawer chest
nothing to doctor chest Danielle look
you're the my god get out the [ __ ] did
you just say dot on a chest a four
drawer chest doctor tell when the looks
a doctor chest
I don't I generally don't know what it
click like is the [ __ ] gunshots I need
are you on the other hand what's better
chances doctor chest you shed it does
the more you speak the more they realize
how come that grow on the back never
speaks because you like dr. Chester
chests I'm going to like look like stop
reduction are we're literally next to a
railroad what I think about la is one
block it could be Heligan is all
industrial I don't know I don't know
maybe I don't know we'll share it
Isla see if this turns out to be 61st
Street oh I thought you said six why did
you click East 61st Street where are we
here
we are literally fifty five streets away
to be I [ __ ] hate all they are stupid
so progressively let's let's talk about
this let's talk so progressively as
we're going right it looks like the
barrio I like I'm like where the [ __ ] is
this
it's like dudes with like garbage bags
swung over the shoulder and she goes
listen listen it okay you know places in
LA one blood is clean and the message
auntie [ __ ] we're not even going the
right place
listen I put it in um it's right please
[ __ ] is tripping because I know East
6-3 isn't downtown right there
right that means we good we're good
so sixth Street to 61st Street we're
literally 55 streets away
you shouldn't have both of us together I
have that I'm just in a car full of
stupid hahahaha that's my lot smarter
than you two dumbasses I didn't get the
sweet girl look call me mistake right
[ __ ] doctor chest 61st Street 6
Street way off one doctor chest here
[ __ ] Google hacks I hate you so much
here she was thinking about you say you
know how pokemons you go to the gym you
know what a really good Pokemon would be
for a [ __ ] gym rat huh or someone who
really likes a gym [ __ ] swallow [ __ ]
that's not that's not funny [ __ ] you a
swole bro that's not funny like somebody
who likes to go to the gym a swole bro
and what would evolve into huh what are
he involved into look what would he
evolve into I know us what look it's
just cute a slice war girl will evolve
into a slow buck yeah because you know
what happens after you stop taking
steroids you get that